my dad always used to say before he
passed you know
he would say you can't you have to
survive not only physically
but you have to survive emotionally i
think a lot of people forget about the
emotional part
of uh survival you have to survive
emotionally and humor
and and and understanding reality in its
objective context helps with that
accepting reality as this
ephemeral uh thing that
you're in really just a part of but not
as significant as your ego wants you to
believe
is a start that's a good foundation for
surviving emotionally
what what's that mean surviving
emotionally like what what's an ideal
life look like for you
you can't take things too seriously you
can't um because
they're ephemeral they're they're not
permanent nothing's permanent your bank
account's not permanent your problems
aren't permanent
uh nothing's permanent your abilities
aren't permanent um your memory is not
permanent your
your dick getting hard is not permanent
can i curse on this or is this go out
yeah you can curse to your heart's
content okay yeah i mean gender is not
even permanent anymore i think i'm gonna
i'm gonna change maybe and live my
second half as another gender just to
have
i'm bored with this gender so it's like
nothing is permanent and so accepting
that
emotionally uh is a good start to being
more flexible you got to be flexible
like my dad used to say anything too
stiff snaps you gotta
you know it's a cliche and people said a
bunch of different ways but bruce lee's
right man be water
be water yeah
bukowski has this quote about love
that love is a fog that phase with the
first light of reality
so he's a romantic that guy yeah but
that even love is a thing that just
doesn't last very long
no um you know some people disagree with
that maybe it morphs it
like like like water it changes right it
might not be
it might not be this because he's mostly
just uh loved like prostitutes i think
so that's kind of love yeah no demand no
uh responsibilities
yeah it's a financial transaction yeah
uh
ephemeral as ever
you